Diagonalizarea cuantică Krylov sau KQD pe scurt se referă la rezolvarea unei probleme de valori proprii ale unei matrice
prin proiectarea matricei într-un subspațiu pregătit pe un calculator cuantic, în concordanță cu metoda Krylov, o
abordare puternică din algebra liniară clasică. Pe parcursul acestui video vom explora la ce este utilă metoda Krylov
și cum și când să o implementăm pe calculatoare cuantice.
Deci ce este metoda Krylov? Să presupunem că avem o matrice H legată de un demers științific sau de afaceri cu n linii și n
coloane. Ne interesează cea mai mică valoare proprie e 0 și vectorul propriu corespunzător psi 0. Să definim un
vector inițial v care poate fi motivat de structura lui h sau poate fi complet aleatoriu. Subspațiul Krylov
de ordinul r, pe care îl scriem k r, este generat prin acțiunea lui h asupra acestui
vector inițial de r minus unu ori, adăugând rezultatul fiecărei acțiuni succesive a lui h
la mulțimea vectorilor de acoperire, adică kr este spațiul acoperit de vectorii v
hv h pătrat și așa mai departe. Acești vectori nu vor fi în general ortogonali.
Clasic, efectuăm adesea un proces de ortogonalizare foarte asemănător cu procedura Graham-Schmidt. Începi
prin normalizarea vectorului inițial V și numești rezultatul V 0. Apoi pentru următorul vector HV, scazi proiecția lui pe
V 0 pentru a face cei doi vectori ortogonali. Apoi normalizezi rezultatul. Continui astfel,
acționând din nou cu H și făcând rezultatul ortogonal față de toți vectorii adăugați anterior, până când ai construit R
vectori ortonormalizați necesari pentru a acoperi subspațiul Krylov de dimensiune R.
Odată ce ai acest subspațiu, proiectezi matricea ta pe el și diagonalizezi matricea proiectată mai mică. Există
subtilități și extensii, dar aceasta este metoda Krylov la cel mai simplu nivel al ei.
Pentru a înțelege mai bine cum funcționează, să privim un exemplu trivial. Dacă H este această matrice și V este ales să fie acest
vector, atunci am începe prin normalizarea lui V. Pentru a genera al doilea vector într-un subspațiu Krylov, acționăm
o dată cu H pe vectorul nostru inițial și apoi facem acel rezultat ortogonal față de V 0.
Puțină algebră ne dă acest rezultat pentru V1.
Aceasta nu este utilă pentru matrice atât de mici și nu ne-am opri în mod obișnuit la o dimensiune Krylov de două. Dar dacă am
proiecta H pe noul nostru spațiu Krylov K2, am face asta folosind o matrice V
care are câte un vector Krylov pentru fiecare coloană și transpusa sa conjugată care are vectori Krylov pe linii. Am obține apoi
această matrice.
Această matrice are tehnic o dimensiune mai mică decât originala noastră. Evident, această reducere nu este utilă la această
scară. Această metodă este destinată reducerii matricelor cu mii sau chiar milioane de linii și coloane
la doar câteva. Deci de ce sunt utile metodele Krylov? Se dovedește că această prescripție simplă
de acțiune a operatorului este adesea cea mai eficientă modalitate de a se apropia de starea cu cea mai mică valoare sau starea fundamentală a unui operator
matriceal. Să facem asta puțin mai explicit, deși vom lăsa o demonstrație completă textului însoțitor. Dorim să
rezolvăm o problemă de forma h acționând pe vectorul x ne dă o constantă înmulțită cu vectorul x. Să începem cu o
aproximare a vectorului propriu x0. Aceasta este doar o soluție aproximativă. Are o eroare pe care o numim e 0. Acum vrem să
facem o actualizare a acestei aproximări pe care o vom numi x1, sperând că îmbunătățim aproximarea noastră. Putem exprima aceasta ca
x0 original plus o corecție p 0 care urmează să fie determinată. Putem
repeta acest proces iterativ adăugând din ce în ce mai mulți vectori de corecție pi.
Evident vrem ca eroarea noastră să fie redusă, dar nu este doar starea de care ne pasă. Ne pasă și de
acțiunea lui h pe acea stare. Deci cantitatea pe care vrem cu adevărat să o minimizăm este norma h a acestei erori sau norma
acțiunii lui h pe această eroare.
Acum putem vedea că aceasta este o expresie care implică p 0 și ne putem întreba ce alegeri ale lui p minimizează
această normă h a erorii cel mai eficient. Din ce spațiu ar trebui să selectăm corecția? În anumite
condiții, cum ar fi atunci când h este simetric și pozitiv definit, alegerea primelor r corecții din kr
se dovedește a fi optimă. În termeni mai simpli, avem nevoie de o modalitate de a pregăti un subspațiu bun pe care să
proiectăm Hamiltonianul nostru. Și în multe cazuri, subspațiul Krylov este spațiul acoperit de vectorii celor mai
eficiente corecții la aproximarea noastră inițială.
Pentru o demonstrație reală, consultă textul care însoțește acest video.
Tot ce am descris până acum poate fi făcut clasic. Deci, cum și când am folosi un calculator cuantic?
Pentru matrice foarte mari, metoda Krylov poate necesita timpi lungi de calcul și cantități mari de memorie. Timpul
necesar pentru operația matriceală a lui H pe V se scalează ca N pătrat în cel mai rău caz.
Și aceasta se face pentru fiecare vector pe care îl dorim în subspațiul nostru. Dimensiunea subspațiului R nu este de obicei o fracție semnificativă
din N și se scalează adesea ca log din N. Deci generarea tuturor vectorilor se scalează
ca ordinul N^2 log N.
Deși există și alți pași cum ar fi ortogonalizarea, aceasta este scalarea dominantă de reținut.
Calculul cuantic ne permite să schimbăm ce atribute ale problemei determină scalarea timpului și resurselor
necesare. În loc de dependența de dimensiunea matricei n pe tot parcursul, vom vedea lucruri precum numărul de shots și
numărul de termeni Pauli necomutanți care alcătuiesc un Hamiltonian.
Să explorăm cum funcționează aceasta.
Amintește-ți că operatorul care evoluează temporal o stare cuantică este exponențiala lui iH împărțit la h bar. Și este
foarte comun, mai ales în calculul cuantic, să se omită h bar din notație.
O modalitate de a înțelege și chiar de a realiza o astfel de funcție exponențială a unui operator este să privim la expansiunea sa în serie Fourier
. Observă că această operație acționând pe un vector inițial V produce o sumă de termeni
WEBVTT
cu puteri crescătoare ale lui H aplicate stării inițiale. Se pare că putem construi subspațiul Krylov prin evoluția temporală
a stării noastre inițiale de ghicire. Și asta e aproape adevărat. Avertismentul constă în
realizarea evoluției temporale pe un calculator cuantic real. Mulți dintre termenii din Hamiltonian nu vor comuta cu
ceilalți. Deci, deși unii operatori exponențiali simpli precum e la puterea negativă i z corespund unor circuit-uri simple,
hamiltonianele generale nu o fac, și deoarece conțin termeni necomutanți
nu putem pur și simplu descompune exponențiala într-un produs de exponențiale simple cum putem face cu numerele. Deci
aceasta nu e trivial, dar este un proces bine studiat în calculul cuantic. Realizăm evoluția temporală
pe calculatoare cuantice folosind un proces numit trotterizare, care în sine este un subiect bogat. Dar la un nivel foarte înalt,
împărțind evoluția temporală în pași mici, să zicem M pași, limităm efectele necomutativității
termenilor. Să numim subspațiul Krylov de ordinul r pe care l-am generat în context clasic folosind puterile lui h
direct subspațiul Krylov de putere kpr.
Acum generăm un spațiu similar folosind operatorul unitar de evoluție temporală u dat de exponențiala lui iht.
Ne vom referi la acesta ca subspațiul Krylov unitar kur.
Subspațiul Krylov de putere kpr pe care îl folosim clasic nu poate fi generat direct pe un calculator cuantic deoarece h
nu este un operator unitar. Se poate demonstra că folosirea subspațiului Krylov unitar oferă garanții de convergență similare
cu subspațiul Krylov de putere.
Mai precis, eroarea stării fundamentale converge eficient atât timp cât starea inițială V are suprapunere cu
starea fundamentală reală care nu este exponențial de mică și atât timp cât există un decalaj suficient între valorile
proprii. Aici puterile lui u devin diferite intervale de timp. A k-a putere a lui u reprezintă avansarea
cu un timp k * dt.
Putem eticheta elementul subspațiului care este evoluat temporal pentru un timp total kdt ca s sub k. Putem proiecta
Hamiltonianul H pe subspațiul Krylov unitar kur. Cu alte cuvinte,
calculăm fiecare element de matrice al lui h în baza kur. Ne vom referi la această
matrice proiectată ca h tilda. Elementele de matrice ale lui H tilda sunt date de aceste valori de așteptare care pot fi
estimate folosind calculatorul cuantic.
Ține minte că H poate fi scris ca o sumă de operatori Pauli pe diferiți qubit-uri și că nu toți operatorii Pauli
pot fi măsurați simultan. Putem sorta termenii Pauli în grupuri de termeni comutanți și măsura toți
aceștia deodată. Dar poate fi nevoie de multe astfel de grupuri pentru a acoperi toți termenii. Deci numărul de grupuri comutante distincte în
care termenii pot fi partiționați ngcp devine important. Dacă folosim un subspațiu Krylov unitar de dimensiune r,
matricea rezultată va avea dimensiunile r * r. Dacă r este mult mai mic decât n, atunci am
făcut progrese utile și de obicei r este mult mai mic decât 100, ceea ce înseamnă că putem diagonaliza aceasta ușor pe un calculator
clasic. Dar amintește-ți că s n și s m nu vor fi în general ortogonali. Uneori este
posibil să diagonalizezi o matrice într-o bază ne-ortogonală. Dar există motive numerice și fizice
pentru a schimba mai întâi la o bază ortogonală. Prin urmare, rezolvăm o problemă generalizată de valori proprii folosind matricea gram s.
Elementul mn al matricei gram este dat de produsul interior al lui s m cu s n.
Atât elementele lui H tilda cât și cele ale lui S sunt calculate folosind un test Hadamard.
Problema generalizată de valori proprii devine apoi aceasta.
Așa cum s-a menționat mai sus, dimensiunea subspațiului Krylov unitar R este exponențial mai mică decât dimensiunea matricei noastre inițiale
N. Deci această problemă de valori este simplă de rezolvat clasic.
Recapitulând, pornim cu o stare de referință, o evoluăm apoi pentru diferite perioade de timp pentru a genera subspațiul Krylov
unitar. Proiectăm Hamiltonianul nostru pe acel subspațiu și estimăm de asemenea suprapunerile
vectorilor subspațiului. În final, rezolvăm clasic problema generalizată de valori de dimensiune mai mică. Să comparăm ce
determină costurile computaționale ale folosirii tehnicii Krylov clasic și mecanic-cuantic. Am schițat aceasta
deja pentru versiunea clasică și nu există analogii perfecte între abordările clasice și cuantice pentru toți pașii. Dar acest tabel colectează câteva
scalări ale diferiților pași pentru analiză. Amintește-ți că Hamiltonianele au în general termeni care nu pot fi măsurați simultan deoarece
nu comută. Sortăm termenii din Hamiltonian în grupuri de operatori Pauli comutanți care pot fi toți măsurați simultan și poate fi nevoie de multe
astfel de grupuri pentru a contabiliza toți termenii care nu comută. Construirea lui H tilda pe un calculator cuantic necesită
măsurători separate pentru fiecare grup de șiruri Pauli comutante din Hamiltonian. Și fiecare dintre acestea necesită mulți shots. Trebuie să facem asta pentru r
pătrat de elemente de matrice diferite corespunzând la r pătrat combinații de factori diferiți de evoluție temporală. Există
uneori modalități de a reduce aceasta. Dar în acest tratament aproximativ, timpul necesar pentru aceasta se scalează aproximativ ca
numărul de shots înmulțit cu numărul de grupuri de termeni Pauli comutanți* r^ 2.
Elementele lui s trebuie estimate, ceea ce se scalează ca numărul de shots
per r la cub. Vedem că diagonalizarea cuantică Krylov poate fi utilă în cazurile în care numărul de grupuri Pauli comutante
din Hamiltonian este relativ mic.
Această dependență de scalare sugerează unele aplicații unde metoda Krylov poate fi utilă și altele unde probabil
nu va fi. Unele Hamiltoniane au complexitate ridicată atunci când sunt mapate pe qubit-uri, implicând multe șiruri Pauli necomutante
care nu pot fi ușor partiționați în câteva grupuri comutante.
Acest lucru este adesea adevărat pentru problemele de chimie cuantică. De exemplu, această complexitate prezintă două provocări principale pentru
calculatoarele cuantice din era apropiată. În primul rând, estimarea fiecărui element al lui H tilda devine costisitoare computațional din cauza
numărului mare de termeni. În al doilea rând, circuit-urile Trotter necesare devin prohibitiv de adânci. Ambele aceste puncte
vor fi mai puțin problematice când calculatoarele cuantice ating toleranța la erori, dar trebuie luate în considerare pe termen scurt. Chiar și sistemele cu mapări mai simple
WEBVTT
decât cele din chimia cuantică pot experimenta aceleași impedimente dacă Hamiltonianele au prea mulți termeni necomutanți.
Metoda Krylov este cel mai utilă acolo unde Hamiltonianul poate fi partiționat în relativ puține grupuri Pauli comutante
și unde H este ușor de implementat în circuit-uri Trotter. Ambele aceste condiții sunt îndeplinite. De
exemplu, pentru multe modele de rețea de interes în fizică, KQD este deosebit de util dacă se știe foarte puțin despre
starea fundamentală. Aceasta derivă din garanțiile sale inerente de convergență și din aplicabilitatea sa în scenarii în care
metodele alternative sunt inabordabile din cauza cunoașterii insuficiente a stării fundamentale.
Deși KQD este un instrument puternic, aspectele consumatoare de timp ale protocolului, în special estimarea fiecărui
element al Hamiltonianului proiectat și suprapunerea stărilor Krylov, reprezintă oportunități de îmbunătățire. O
abordare alternativă implică aproximarea stării Krylov folosind circuit-uri Trotter, apoi eșantionarea
stării aproximate pentru a obține o proiecție pe baza computațională și apoi proiectarea lui h pe subspațiul
acoperit de aceste stări ale bazei computaționale.
În cazurile în care este aplicabilă, această metodologie cunoscută sub numele de diagonalizare cuantică Krylov bazată pe eșantionare SKQD
oferă potențial reduceri semnificative ale cerințelor de timp și resurse față de KQD tradițional.
Integrarea tehnicilor de subspațiu Krylov cu metodele de eșantionare în SKQD reprezintă o frontieră interesantă în
algoritmii cuantici.